Speaker 1: Today, I bring you the next installment,
the latest episode in these are my principles
until they conflict with the facts, and this
is a really common theme on the right when
there is a shooting involving a black or Muslim
perpetrator or a violent protest with property
damage or some horrible murder.
The right is very quick to say it's about
the parents.
Blame the parents.
Single parent households are to blame.
Liberal households are bad for not instilling
the right values in these perpetrators parents,
parents, parents.
And then we have a situation where the parents
are really to blame and have been criminally
charged.
And now the problem is the school where the
shooter went what?
This is beyond parody, but it's what they're
doing when this horrible school shooting took
place in Oxford, Michigan.
The parents of the teenager who committed
the shooting have actually been charged for
involuntary manslaughter, and then they went
on the run.
Police eventually found them.
They've now been arraigned, formally charged.
They are being charged because of the allegedly
unrestricted access that their son, the shooter,
had to the gun that he's accused of using
in the shooting.
Finally, we're holding the parents accountable,
right?
Fox News and right wing media should be cheering
and saying, we are so glad that finally the
focus is on the family.
And oh, they're not.
No.
Here is Fox News host Judge Jeanine Pirro
saying, we've got to blame, I hope you're
sitting.
We have to blame the liberal school personnel
at the school for this shooting.
You really can't write this stuff.
Speaker 4: And then there's Oxford, Michigan,
with Ethan Crumbly, who shot and killed four
students and injured seven others, including
a teacher, for no reason because liberal school
personnel should have known crumbly, had a
gun or at least had access to one, but never
bothered to ask the very reason they told
his parents to come to class instead of suspending
him immediately.
And then they let him go right back into class.
Speaker 1: So this time it was the fault of
the school workers who didn't act to take
away the gun from their kid.
This time it's the school worker's fault.
So fundamentally, what is this really about?
It's about the parents being Trump supporting
right wing nuts.
There's no reason to mince words.
There's no reason to pretend it's anything
else.
The Michigan school massacre suspect's mother
wrote a letter to Trump praising Trump for
his support of gun rights.
Gushing about her ability to be a realtor
and have her guns wither, she praised Trump
for the border wall.
She complained about parents at other schools
where the kids come from illegal immigrant
parents and don't care about learning.
And she said, that's what this is about the
principle of look to the family.
Look to the parents that they so dearly cling
to when it's convenient, flies away like dandelions
spores.
Once the principal is no longer convenient
the way it is here because the parents are
Trump supporters, that's all it is.
And this is another reason why I encourage
you not to get sucked into the principal's
black hole with these right wingers.
You something I've experienced so often when
I take calls from the audience and in other
situations is David, please tell me where
you are on the principles of this or that.
I'm for freedom, family and non aggression.
Those are my principles.
Great.
How do we solve climate change on the basis
of your principles?
And it goes nowhere.
Principles are valuable.
In creating a baseline for solving real world
problems and figuring out specific situations,
but the principles alone don't solve the problems
for you unless you know how to apply them.
And maybe most importantly, it's a waste of
time to argue principles with these people
because they don't even really stand by the
principles when the principles start to contradict
their preconceived notions of how the world
should be organized.
Now, should we give Judge Jeanine credit for
blaming school personnel instead of critical
race theory?
Maybe, right?
I mean, given the environment, I sort of expected
that's the direction she would go.
She didn't.
But the parents are no longer a source of
concern for pro-family advocate Judge Jeanine
Pirro.
Let me know your thoughts.
We're going to have more on this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram.
Find it at David Pakman show and make sure
you're following me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break
and be
right back.